we bring in the cowboys star rookie
linebacker the pride of Riggins Idaho
Layton Vander Ashe who joins us on the
program Layton good morning how are you
good morning good morning I'm doing
great
do good how are you well we got some
questions here about your name and you
got to help us here are you Dutch yes
okay yep
okay now Vander Ashe is two words here
explain the van der and and then the ash
if you can I think it's all just us
origin
it's just split up into two parts I'm
not really sure why it's like that but
that's just how it is all right that's
it that's all I wanted to talk to you
about and have a good season thank you
Leighton okay now we we came in and my
producer Paul egos Ian this whole van
Dhiresh why is it two words why is it
not just van der ash it's one word so
that was that was yes Pauline we found a
village in the Netherlands called ash
and that may be the homeland of it late
yeah that's possible I could very well
be it I just know there's a lot there's
a lot like a lot of Dutch names is that
way they've broken up in a - so are you
there are you the greatest Dutch
linebacker in the NFL I don't know let's
start this interview over let's bring in
the Cowboys star rookie linebacker
Leighton van der eschew joins us now the
pride of Riggins Idaho how many people
in Riggins Idaho and then you go from
there to Boise State did you get any
offers coming out of high school
scholarship boys I had a bunch of offers
for smaller schools like any high
schools I didn't have eb1 offers so I
was just trying to battle through that
knowing that someone was gonna come
sooner or later but I always wanted to
play a Boise so they offered me to walk
on there and I wasn't turning that down
I always wanted to play there so yeah
for me what did you think of that blue
field the first time you saw him
I thought all the time I grew up
watching the games as a little kid
normally games and and I did enjoy the
experience that way but actually getting
it getting to be able to ride on the
field before the game and play on it was
all a little what did you expect this
year coming into the NFL as a rookie um
that's a good question too uh I thought
I thought it was gonna take a little bit
of time you're going but obviously even
thrusting into a position I am now with
Sean being down and just starring in a
moment and making the most of it just
being confident myself what was the
welcome to the NFL moment to be honest
with you I've been asked that a few
times here and there but I mean that
first OTA practice I guess you could say
like no lines a lot faster than in
college like I could not endure that
only took like a few snaps and maybe a
day of practice but other than that I
mean it's just been it's been pulled o
gunblade but you get out there and
everybody says that you know the game is
so fast but then the great ones always
say eventually the game slows down I
think just because you get used to that
speed have you gotten used to the speed
of the NFL yeah I think there's
definitely there's some teams or some
teams a little bit different dollars so
you gotta get used to that that way but
I think for the most part the game is
his has flown down quite a bit since the
beginning of the episode of season so
just taking that from there and they
keep gain confidence keep TV an
experience out there no one was coming
and just playing it fast
being aggressive what was your opinion
reaction thoughts when you first met
Jerry Jones
but I was on my official visit my phone
visit here in the spring and I got to
talk to him in his office and that was
the first time I had ever been around
like that I mean he's awesome he's he's
the real deal
he's a true businessman he knows his
stuff
he's extremely sharp and he just didn't
really a respectable guy you don't do an
impersonation of Jerry Jones - no no
good answer there very good
I talked to Jaylon Smith last week and I
asked him how much he benched max bench
you know what he said what he said 490
ok how much can you bent 1 1 rap let's
go wait hold on let ok let's go around
the room here
Layton Vander ash fritzy how much do you
think that is max benches
I'm gonna go 425 425 McLovin 450 or 50
Paulie metric system cuz he's Dutch no
I'm gonna go for 40 even or 40 Seaton
i'ma go 420 420 yeah I'm kind of in that
bin I was gonna go Wayman hold on here
hold on hold on
I'm gonna go 394 leighton van der ash
max bench 1 rep the other albeit
generous generous I think but I think
the you're the closest of the last one I
would say three ninety four hundred okay
all right fair enough
you know Jaylon Smith probably laughs at
that like he warms up with that he does
curls with that I think Layton yeah how
would you explain you guys lose three or
four and then you win four straight so
what happened I think this has been our
mindset and energy and mentality we've
been having the last four weeks knowing
that our backs against the wall and now
we have to go out there and get it done
I think we play our breaths when we have
that mentality and we just got to keep
that going and
being consistent every single week so
yeah I just having fun with each other
feeding off each others energy humming
we got a young team so there's having
fun playing football with each other
he's late in Van der ash the Cowboys
rookie linebacker joining a stand
Patrick show any quarterback start you
know fanboy stuff you know you're facing
drew Brees any of that where you're
going oh my god you know I just sacked
or tackled or intercepted or any of
those moments um yeah I think you're
playing against agent Peterson was
pretty it was pretty special
hmm obviously I grew up in and he was
one of my favorite players and so
getting to play against him finally was
absolutely insane gonna tackle him and
and go up against a guy of his caliber
obviously because you can see he still
got it he can still he can still make
those runs he can he can still do it he
gets to run the show on the field so I
get to play games awesome yeah you had a
90-yard touchdown run last night does
anybody call you baby giraffe I know
that that was a nickname I don't know if
it's still a nickname nobody calls me
baby giraffe anymore yeah that one kind
of wasn't when gone what happened I
don't know I think I grew out of it oh
so you're just a giraffe you're not a
baby giraffe anymore what about wolf
hunter is that still applicable here as
a nickname yeah yeah that's definitely
still definitely still one you can you
can use giraffe process from coach's
chart we talked I think we talked more
about hunting the whole entire time
rather than football stuff and
everything so yeah that made am kind of
stuck okay but you don't are you making
that wolf sound during games yeah I mean
they play they play in the stadium they
played in the stadium after big plays or
whatever so I mean you gotta go with it
I mean you can't hear it cuz the
speakers are blare how so yeah that's
good I like it hey congrats on the
season it's a big transition for anybody
and you've made it seamless there for
the cowboy so Leighton thank you for
joining us and playing along you have no
problem thank you for having that's
Leighton van Dhiresh for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]